welcome to hannity all right tonight the
people of wyoming they have spoken and
after losing by nearly 40 points to
harriet hageman in last night's primary
liz cheney's days in congress now are
officially numbered liz sadly could not
see the forest through the trees she
allowed her hatred for donald trump and
trump supporters to consume her
this became cheney's singular focus in
life there was no bridge she wouldn't
burn no colleague she wouldn't betray no
voters that she wouldn't ignore she put
her own agenda and her self-righteous
obsession above the people that she was
elected to serve this people that are
elected are public servants in many ways
she showed utter contempt for the people
in her own state and they didn't like it
one bit and oddly this led congresswoman
cheney to align with the very same
democrats and i find this the oddest
thing of all who called her own father a
war criminal look at what they did to
scooter libby his chief of staff they
called her father a murderer
a crook for working on halliburton the
very same people that smeared her family
for decades and then there were people
like myself who defended her father and
people like scooter libby you know were
now just dismissed as unethical without
any principal values whatsoever she
would clearly rather have joe biden and
the democrats in charge of the country
with all of their destructive policies
it's more dangerous than ever instead of
donald trump the people of wyoming
disagree with her and the numbers they
speak for themselves the people have
spoken now liz cheney has pledged to
continue her anti-trump crusade probably
serving as
a token anti-trump republican on what
fake news cnn or msdnc
now harriet hegman meanwhile will serve
the people of wyoming on capitol hill
and that brings us to tonight's top
story we are now tonight 83 days away
from the midterm elections that will be
held on tuesday november the 8th and
according to brand new poll numbers by
reuters 70 of you the american people
believe that our country is on the wrong
track we are democrats have controlled
the senate the house and the white house
for two long years and it has been a
disaster make no mistake there is only
one way to begin the process of turning
this
around for all of us the gop has got to
win control of both the house and the
senate in the house minority leader
kevin mccarthy he's been on this program
he has outlined a plan a new nationwide
contract with america and the american
people he's calling it the commitment to
america every republican running will
sign it that is in the house all
democrats incessantly are pushing a far
left far-reaching radical socialist
quote transition their favorite word
house republicans will run on a few key
principles designed to improve the lives
of every american that includes a much
stronger economy with less government
bureaucracy that means lower taxes on
individuals and businesses alike the gop
is also committed to an actual plan to
reduce this 41-year high of inflation by
unleashing american energy it's great
for national security reasons it's great
to get rid of inflation and lower that
uh record high energy prices it will
reduce that and that means the cost of
every item you buy at every store you go
to will be cheaper how great would that
be job creation high paying career jobs
in the energy sector this is essential
to save this country on the other side
democrats including joe and kamala well
they're just pretending like inflation
no longer exists
huh take a look
the president and my vision for the
future also means lowering costs
for americans today we learned
that last month our economy had zero
percent inflation i just want to say a
number
zero
today we received news that our economy
had zero percent inflation
in the month of july
zero percent
now they said this right after the
report came out showed inflation at a
whopping 8.5 percent another four decade
high
high under the republican plan we could
begin the process to bring these numbers
down remember when joe came into office
the
consumer price index was only 1.4
percent we can do it by increasing
energy production becoming energy
dominant even remember we were a net
exporter of energy under donald trump
and we achieved energy independence for
the first time in 75 years keep in mind
america could produce enough cheap clean
burning natural gas to supply not just
the united states but every one of our
allies in western europe so they won't
have to count on vladimir putin for the
lifeblood of their economy now of course
your safety and security that's also a
key part of the commitment to america
that means securing our southern border
stopping the spread of fentanyl and
heroin flooding into this country
locking up violent criminals
getting rid of these no bail laws and
defunding and dismantling police
departments and no more lacks
prosecutions cities and states have got
to be held accountable for letting these
criminals back out on the street we need
safe towns safe cities all across
america and don't forget your kids
they've got to be protected and that
means you need as a parent parental
rights and your child's education and
you ought not worry about being
investigated as a domestic terrorist if
you go to a school board meeting and
speak out on behalf of age-appropriate
materials being taught your kids and by
the way those schools ought to be
teaching reading writing math science
history computers not critical race
theory or radical gender theory let the
parents teach that at home or if you
want an opt-in program after school have
at it finally the gop will hold the
federal government accountable with
oversight on the biden white house the
doj the upper echelon of the fbi
including an important focus on
preserving your liberty your freedom and
your constitutional rights this is a
simple and effective message that will
resonate with the american people in 84
days in every state unfortunately in the
senate i have no reason why this
mysterious reluctance resistance of
mitch mcconnell he doesn't seem too
interested in making commitments to the
american people i guess you know he'd
rather what leave senate candidates out
to try to fend for themselves in states
where democrats are attempting to win by
isolating republican candidates smearing
individual candidates in order to
distract voters from the democratic
party's many failures look if joe
manchin taught us one thing it's simply
this at the end of the day the democrats
always vote with one voice and with each
passing day that voice is more and more
like the devout socialist bernie sanders
this is now bernie's party they worship
at the altar of climate alarmism and
climate change it's a cult just last
week in order to fund a green energy
slush fund every single democrat in the
senate voted for a bill that increases
your taxes on your electric bills
increases your taxes on gas increases
your taxes on every barrel of oil either
we produce domestically or import into
this country it also increases taxes on
small businesses it increases taxes on
americans making as little as thirty
thousand dollars a year and it funds
eighty seven thousand new irs agents to
go out collect and audit you the
american people if you make twenty five
thousand dollars or less according to
syracuse university you are five times
more likely to get audited they ran this
bill through under a process known as
reconciliation the same way they passed
obamacare and that only requires a
50-vote majority they don't need cloture
and they'll do it again next year if
given the chance now you have warnock in
georgia you have val demings in florida
you have the socialist john fetterman of
bernie number two in pennsylvania and
every other democrat running for the
senate support this radical climate
alarmist agenda new green deal socialism
they're all on a radical green energy
socialist transit transition plan as
they like to call it so let's be clear
this is not a guaranteed wave election
anyone that says republicans have a lock
on the house and the senate they're
lying to you they don't know the races
can be extremely competitive in every
bellwether state this is really for the
country in all hands on deck situation
this is an inflection point for the
country if your preferred candidate by
the way didn't win the primary i'm sorry
that they didn't win too bad but if you
don't support the republican uh in the
race you're going to get the government
you deserve and that government will be
run by far left climate alarmists
they'll be the ones stacking the supreme
court ending the legislative filibuster
going forward with d.c statehood and
every other power grab you can think of
they'll be hell-bent on pushing this
agenda down your throat hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else